e la tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono quello che fa e pista
ragazzi oggi episodi normale che è che
che poi che dire sembra spesso perché vi
aspettate sempre come se dovessi di oggi
facciano oggi un episodio norma normale
oggi tranquilli stratega calmati che ti
vedo agitato calma chi stai fermo il
prossimo 99 per cento ragazzi partiamo
subito con viva l'italia
beh certo come possiamo chiamarlo se non
viva italia però scriviamo in inglese
ovviamente le zone forza italia a only
for lupo e cioè se non riesco a vincere
prendo la moneta ma io la moneta non la
prendo perché io a vincere ovviamente ci
riesco visto che forse conviene
prenderlo però io gioco talmente quindi
puoi prendere la bomba e fake call cosa
fosse pensavo fosse un muretto per la
bomba invece la puoi prendere
d'altro spiegatemi come è stata
possibile quest'area terminati
fammi capire un secondo
grazie al traguardo ma come non ho
toccato niente bmx porci questo è
difficile addirittura scritto pure
edifici come se fosse un migliaio happy
days amici miei sono tatuato sulla
fascia vuoi che non riesco a farli
veloci dopo 60 anni di happy with ci
hanno pensato una volta di tab armi e
quindi sul corpo più precisamente sulla
chiama perché comunque è stato penso il
gioco più significativo della mia
carriera
poi ha detto forse è meglio se mitato
mia suocera però effettivamente sono
situazioni da valutare cosa che magari
potrei pensare di fare se finisco questo
livello ma
io gli ostacoli non mi vedo neanche per
me non esiste non esistono gli ostacoli
smettetela di pensare che pure è
difficile voglia scrivere chirurgia dai
fuochi jerman slate
[Musica]
ok best boss barese a beh certo essere
pro per una sorta di boltro però avevi
che nel mondo il vostro lavoro inventato
mostro prima c'è la fila il basket vuole
un bowl trovo quindi stephen curry è uno
dei boltro visti più famosi al mondo
cioè se leggeri ed aspetta chiave
vecchia ott
vi piace oliveri platform che non è un
platform questo prendiamo per il porco
prendiamo anche questo 14 snow va bè
ragazzi bellissimo come si chiamano sti
livelli che vi voglio fare tantissimo
1470 ok 470 e non ci passo non ci passo
aiuto a no lo fosse qua sotto ok
[Musica]
pannello di controllo
apri ci siamo 1470 è vero neanche al
codice l'ho già aperto
sapete che devo far entrare in corsa
incredibile che sono le stesse a questo
punto come si chiamano ragazzi livelli
perché mi piacciono tantissimo è cosa
devo fare
oddio è ok i cinesi
half life piano 29 ragazzi livello e
bellissimo carminello bellissimo questo
guarda e da top del mondo secondo me è
fatto veramente bene che piano si chiama
stiano sotto floor e white lake golf
plus d'or a me cioè ragazzi è fatto
davvero benissimo ogni tanto nel nel
browser even cioè quelli settimanali
tramite livelli di brno è già finito
ma come era bellissimo voglio fare un
sacco di livelli così come si chiamano
come posso distinguerli sono ben puzzle
puzzle lever bellissimo works trueblue
ed abiti da gara e david teague dischord
noi mi piace tisti non so come mai tac
[Musica]
123 sporco del demonio maledizione
questo è veramente difficile ragazzi
difficile perché sono tutti impostati
male circolano lo posso prendere c'è la
barriera come l'avvocato non è possibile
ma dai ragazzi possa aprire la mia sulla
mia materia scuola aprile va bene non so
parlare posso dar vita a questa la
materia che la tav è più il montreux
ragazzi non so purtroppo l'effetto
questo pesto il basket quello vero ciao
miliardo profonda il suo pinguini marino
penso di esserci arrivato
funziona così il basket come pg1 bru ma
basta sul tipo a sottotipo il trono che
sono la tipa come teatro preso la morte
non me l'ha presa cioè non so come sia
possibile però vabbè
ero andato sulla morte e non mi ha preso
la morte quindi ok ma oggi un fenomeno
sono cosa succede oggi che puntava
incredibile solidità ad un fenomeno in
tutto il ma solo oggi voi tra l'altro
c'è da anni impossible il jet tran della
vita che non è possibile che sono
trovati col padre di youtube su parolisi
è un centro annesse insorgenti corrono
contro non quelli che tu usi gente
infatti pensato che saranno già pechino
non sono un becchino estivo possono
neanche un normale sono medium colori
cody che legge il pensiero neanche a
fare ho tirato una facciata a terra e
sono morto ok
l'obiettivo ragazzi motivo che è partito
non vale era partito un razzo prima
perché era finito un braccio a caso
volevo dire l'obiettivo e colori
sbarazzarsi prima possibile perché
maledetto braccio stato ce n'è uno
conficcato nel collo mi spiegate tutto
ciò come può essere possibile solo nun
se extreme come potrei mai finire quello
madonna per ragazzi ma vi rendete conto
neanche uno ora sono vivo che non ho e
non posso non posso finirlo quello cioè
rendetevi conto è impossibile
quell extreme ma neanche se ne cocco uno
per volta già questo parco ma questa
potrebbe essere una tattica non è male
come idea triciclo
[Musica]
aiuto sarà vivo
oddio oddio oddio come ho fermato questa
che non lo so sono vivo con quale culo
abnorme ho fatto questa cosa vai vai vai
vai di caricare a bestia a bestia no non
si può fare ho appurato che non si può
fare è stato bellissimo arrivare fila ad
un run 96 per cento imposti lo pensi che
gli album un run a distanza di anni
possano sono morte stavo per fare tutto
un discorso serio ma a quanto pare non
ne sono nelle condizioni donna
impossibile è veramente impossibile
lavorare alla madonna perfette buono e
vuole morozzo mi ha ucciso ne uccise una
mania stranissima è partito dopo cielo è
partito prima è ucciso dopo non è mai
successo e non a scorrano
fermi tutti schivare gli arpioni è
un'arte e io la possiede anche sedersi
in questo modo è un'arte ok ok ok ok il
sellino massa da qualcuno li prego
guarda questa roba
il se ha una certa il sellino mi ha
salvato il culo ma tantissimo guardate
non qua questa dopo vi prego alla the
stellino come mi salva il culo madonna
mi ha bloccato l'arpione bellissimo
belli non mi e nova beh questo penso sia
mai successa una roba del genere 9 tutto
per cento impossible words oggi
impossibile ragazzi stanno diventando
un'istituzione non so come mai dato poi
andare di sopra volendo spettatori ci
provo proviamoci nel prossimo livello ci
avranno messo qualcosa per forza vc
gioco quello che volete vediamo perché
ci può arrivare troppo facilmente se ci
fu un altro traguardo
sicuro come non ci sono traguardi nasca
eccolo non sapevo ragazzi viewfinder
sigle non sapevo perché conosco talmente
bene chi non solo il gioco ma anche chi
fai livelli che che io le soste cose
quindi dell'idea appuntamento non
trovando già bravi e ve lo finisco anche
normalmente perché sono un problema di
epic wings e me ne vanto
favole ultima ragazzi molte nubi su il
bellissimo stato insieme o anche rubato
m dct uno di dos stavolta eseguiti nr
swing dove chi lo deve centrare lo swing
anche peso partisse dopo avevo visto
rock swing cavallo bellissima idea tra
lo scegli tu livello che fai bellissimo
raga potrebbe essere un'idea fare sei
livelli in uno fai ogni ogni casella
porco del demonio ogni casella una roma
diversa qua sul tronco arab spring qua
harpoon run e in base a quello che
vecchi ti parte livello sopra figata
ragazzi premettiamolo di brevetti di
eclipse
mau mau rob bowling l'ho rifatto perché
non ci sono riuscito
è mia e rosi con sacco quindi va ma non
perfetto effetto non è vero sono vivo
solo illustrativo tranquilli
bocciate far rumore
cosa di ferme viola non ho capito questo
dovrebbe essere roba spero che vi sia
piaciuto mimando un bacino iscrivetevi
scambio della campanellina primati
raggiunti di univideo ragazzi come
sempre è noi ci rivediamo al prossimo
video del ragazzo
[Musica]